let's get to what the top story of the
day is and it all flows from this this
question that the NFL would very much I
assume like to continue to kick down the
road but in recent days really starting
with that player video last Thursday the
commissioners response Friday it feels
like the momentum is building for the
league to do something with Colin
Kaepernick whether it's apologize
whether it's find a spot for him with a
team that isn't going away it was on the
late-night talk shows on Monday night
Jimmy Fallon mentioned it in his
monologue Trevor Noah on Comedy Central
minute mentioned it as well it's not
going away and here's a prime example of
how it's not going away came up
yesterday during the George Floyd
funeral in Houston the Reverend Al
Sharpton delivering the eulogy at the
George Floyd funeral and Al Sharpton had
a message for the Commissioner regarding
Colin Kaepernick all this family wants
is justice oh it's nice to see some
people change their mind head of the NFL
said Yael maybe we was wrong football
players maybe they did have the right to
peacefully protest well don't apologize
give Colin Kaepernick a job back
[Music]
don't come with some empty apology take
a man's livelihood strip a man down of
his talents and four years later when
the whole world is marching all of a
sudden you go and do a FaceTime talking
about you sorry minimizing the value of
our lives you solid been repaid the
damage you did to the career you stood
down cuz when Colin took a knee he took
it for the families in this building and
we don't want an apology we want him
repaid you know that's that's the point
and that's why Colin Kaepernick's name
is back at the forefront Chris as we
processed what happened to George Floyd
on that Street in Minneapolis murdered
on camera for all to see a real-time
execution broadcast around the world
thanks to the fact that everyone's
carrying a camera now it underscored the
message that Colin Kaepernick was trying
to send the message that got obscured
that got ignored that got downplayed by
everyone who continued to cling to the
idea that it was inherently an
automatically disrespectful of the flag
the country in the military to kneel
during the national anthem the NFL black
ball and Colin Kaepernick and look we
know by now that he wasn't given equal
treatment as it relates to other
available quarterbacks he's never had no
doubt he had one visit in three years
right and and so that's why the call is
there to give him what was taken from
him three years ago Chris yeah well yeah
he was screwed over there's no doubt
about it he was a man that was ahead of
the times and hey the the simple fact of
the matter is white America just didn't
want to open their eyes to the facts of
what is going on with police brutality
or social and justices or anything like
that now at least I'm not going to say
white America's eyes are totally open
right now but
one of them's peeked open where it's
like whoa wait some stuffs going on you
woke some people up here and of course
this reignites the colin kaepernick
conversation because you had the NFL did
him wrong there's no doubt about it I
mean Mike yeah I I wasn't doing
quarterback list but I've had people ask
me over the last few days you actually
text me yesterday going you know where
would colin kaepernick land in the top
40 now and i said i don't know it's been
too long I don't think I would put him
in the top 40 right now but to the point
is when he was blackballed by the NFL
after the 26 2016 season there is like
no doubt you can't argue it if you're
watching football he was in the top half
of the league as far as starting
quarterbacks or at least the top 20 you
know when you talk about a guy who's six
three and a half and has unbelievable
speed and an unreal arm and his battle
tested and played in the Super Bowl and
it was down and brought his team back I
mean there's really no other way to
explain why Colin Kaepernick was not in
the lead of course he was a starting
caliber quarterback and at the very
least even if he didn't like that
because of some of the issues or
whatever it may be he'd be one of the
best backups in football so he was
totally done wrong by the NFL because of
his stand and because white America
didn't like it and we didn't want to
hear it so we changed the subject and
kind of made him the bad guy in a lot of
ways and that's why we are where we are
now but I think a lot of people have
realized that they were in the wrong and
that this is a real thing Malcolm
Jenkins the Saints safety appeared on
CBS this morning yesterday he was asked
by Gayle King if the Roger Goodell video
was enough of a way to make things right
for the players regarding everything
that's happened here's Malcolm Jenkins I
still don't think they've got a right
until they apologize specifically to
Colin Kaepernick or sign him to a team I
don't think that they'll end up on the
right side of history at the end of the
day
listen to her players they've donated
money they've created inspired change
platform they've tried to do things up
into this point it's been one player in
particular that they have not already
they've ignored and have not
acknowledged and that's colin kaepernick
yeah was that the big elephant in the
room that colin kaepernick wasn't
mentioned in the in roger goodell
statement I think so yeah that's the
only thing that people want to hear you
know if it is not going to correct that
or acknowledge that you know then
everything else you know it doesn't need
to be said Malcolm Jenkins again on CBS
this morning and look that's one of the
things that that keeps coming up
regardless of whether or not one of the
32 teams will offer Colin Kaepernick a
job or at a minimum just bring him in
for a tryout and see what he currently
has should the Commissioner have
mentioned Colin Kaepernick by name in
that video response last week to the
video from the players remember the
players wanted the league to admit it
was wrong for silencing players and
obviously Colin Kaepernick is the one
who was most clearly silenced the
response was the NFL via the
commissioner said it was wrong for not
listening should the name Colin
Kapernick have been brought up by the
Commissioner should the Commissioner or
someone else from the league come out
now and say unequivocally they apologize
to Colin Kaepernick I think so I mean
you know yes and yes both both you know
first off I do think that the NFL should
have addressed Colin Kaepernick or Roger
Goodell should have addressed it in that
statement he made you know it's this is
a guy in whose life's been turned upside
down
and obviously it's turned the NFL world
upside down a little bit too to where
you know players are you know very
passionate about the subject and of
course feel that Colin Kaepernick was
wronged in a very bad way to where hey
he's the face of this movement there's
no doubt about that so I do think an
apology or some sort of acknowledgment
to Colin Kaepernick and you know and the
fact that you know he was leading the
charge in a fight way before its time or
you know we just
listen like I said before but I do now
look at it and think yeah there probably
needs to be some sort of statement going
forward from the NFL just to again
acknowledge that Colin Kaepernick was
extremely smart and of course doing
something that he felt was right for
people and the right decision not
necessarily popular to everybody's eyes
but he opened up eyes and not enough and
again I think they should apologize if
nonetheless and just say man if we would
have listened to you and taking you more
seriously maybe we wouldn't be here
right now I know there's a lot of pride
there's a lot of ego that gets tied up
in admitting that someone was wrong and
there's a lot of poison between the NFL
and Colin Kaepernick because of the
collusion claim that he made it was
litigated and when your lawyer is asking
tough pointed questions to owners that
creates hard feelings owners don't like
being asked questions of any kind about
why they've made decisions or didn't
make certain decisions they don't like
to be accused of anything and very good
lawyers know how to create that setting
and create that tone that makes it hard
to build a bridge but I think at this
point we all kind of realize it's
necessary and I think that's the
awakening that the NFL needs to have
that it needs to find a way to make it
right with Colin Kaepernick and it can't
be artificial it can't seem forced it
can't seem contrived it has to be
organic and has to be authentic it has
to be natural and the problem is the
longer it takes them to do it the more
contrived it's going to look if the
natural time to do it would have been at
the moment the rest of us were saying
see Colin Kaepernick had a point and we
should have listened to him instead of
silencing him and and if you're not
gonna do it in the aftermath of the Drew
Brees issue from last week it just
becomes more glaring the longer that
you'll wait now apologizing is one thing
employing is another al sharpton said
employ others have said apologize Matt
Ryan quarterback in the Atlanta Falcons
chimed in on his belief as to whether or
not Colin Kaepernick should have a job
right now in the NFL here's Matt Ryan
you know call him being back in the
league I think he should have every
opportunity to you know
he created awareness for first situation
that you know people it's taken some
time but people are becoming you know
more active in terms of their response
to it and so I think from that
standpoint is his you know protest is
being heard at this point and might have
taken too long and you know but I think
you should have every opportunity to
have a job and to have a spotlessly
that's Matt Ryan who entered the league
three years before Colin Kapernick a
predicts only thirty two as quarterbacks
go that that's smack dab middle of the
prime right right and for a guy who
hasn't been out of the league for three
years at a point where there's an
understanding of Defense's and pre snap
looks and that computer that is your
brain has seen so much that you're
really getting into that sweet spot
where you've still got the physical
skills but you've seen enough and you've
experienced enough where you can be a
high level performer really into your
40s as we've seen or at least close to
your 40s before it starts to fall apart
so here's the question uh and and what
what will take up the physical reality
before we even get because I made the
point earlier this week that now is the
time for Colin Kaepernick's name to be
moved back into the column back onto the
list of the guys who are available every
team has that list if you've ever been
to a team facility and Chris I know you
have they've got the I'm talking about
anyone out there who may be listening
what what they have somewhere in the
facility there's a room that has a list
of all the players on their roster
separated by position and then elsewhere
and everybody does it differently but
but the teams that but you got right
right so you've got you've got every
position and you've got the depth chart
and then you've got a list for each
position of who you would call if and
when one of these guys gets injured
can't get it done whatever the case may
be and the listing you know it goes
eight nine players deep running back
quarterback receiver corner
every position and it gives you a sense
of how interchangeable these parts are
and how heartless of a business it is
when it comes down to the churn like all
this guy's outfits take his name off
pull another one on let's call this guy
I mean that's what they have to do the
problem is Colin Kaepernick's name
hasn't been on that list everybody
everyone's been afraid to consider him
for a job and it started in early 2017
when the false narratives were being fed
to people in the media who were lapping
it up like a bowl of fresh milk straight
from the utter that well he doesn't
really want to play well he's a vegan I
mean Tom Brady's been sucking down
avocado ice cream for years now and we
applaud him well he's a vegan oh ho ho
we can't have somebody who doesn't eat
meat playing quarterback in the National
Football League what the hell was all
this nonsense and there weren't many
that saw through it there were plenty
who were just going along I think they
sensed a you know what it's in my
interest to go along with this even if
it's wrong it was wrong it was wrong
then and it's wrong now so the question
is are we at a moment where I don't know
half a fourth any of the coaches GM's
and owners will say okay here's our list
of available quarterbacks the first guy
we're going to call is this guy the
second one call is this guy weighs comic
haven't gonna be on that list for any
teams yeah I mean that's the
million-dollar question Mike and I think
it's it's you know it's dicey and again
I don't you know I want to make it be
known here and be very clear I'm all for
what Colin Kaepernick did in the fight
and everything about it he got screwed
over like I said but I think when you
purely talk football okay and you just
get into that now and I know it's not
fair that we're in this situation
because the NFL they dug this hole but I
do think realistically as an NFL head
coach right now you're gonna look at
Colin Kaepernick and go man do I really
want to bring this guy in and you know
most teams the way it is they keep two
quarterbacks now you can keep three but
regardless they're gonna go do I want to
bring them in and have the distraction
one okay we know that all right
ba ba ba but the bigger thing is the
football the coaches are gonna go man
three years out of football that's a
long time especially at the quarterback
position I mean you know the
the quarterback positions the hardest
position in all of sports to emulate
what you have to do on the field and
he's not getting to practice with teams
or do anything like that so no he won't
be as mentally sharp
yes physically even though if he's in
shape which I I know he is it's still
gonna be different than getting used to
playing football again - let alone yes I
think teams are gonna be reluctant just
because it's been so long right now you
know I missed a year of football and I
remember coming back Mike and playing my
first preseason game feeling like whoa I
gotta put the training wheels on here
again I don't feel comfortable and then
the last part of it Mike to me is if the
a dude bring him in and now let's say he
doesn't have a great training camp in
pre-season you have to cut them I think
teams will be very scared of what that
might mean and the backlash they'll get
and the conversations that'll get
started there as well so I think that's
what makes it really difficult this is
deja vu all over again because we had
this same conversation I know as my
point continues to be don't worry about
the backlash you're gonna get when you
bring him in and don't worry about the
backlash you're gonna get if you decide
to let him go one of the new tweaks of
the CBA allows teams to have too many
practice squad who are as veteran as
they care to be it could be a 40 year
old guy on the practice squad he can be
around for 20 years in the NFL he can be
on the practice squad you could carry
him on the practice squad and when you
think about Al Sharpton's words that
they need to repair Colin Kaepernick
maybe we don't think about this not in
terms of well just put in his name back
on the list if a quarterback gets
injured if our backups not getting it
done in training camp or in pre-season
let's bring someone in for a tryout and
see if he's better maybe it's something
more than that maybe it's going to take
something and maybe the right thing to
do here given what was done to him that
this is different than the usual
situation where a guy's name is on a
list of players who get called in the
event there's a need at that position
this is a guy who as you said Chris was
screwed by the NFL technical term right
screwed by the NFL screwed by the team's
shunned blackballed for three years
filed a collusion claim and the NFL
wrote him a check how often is the NFL
voluntarily write a check in response to
any type of a legal claim they fight
they fight they fight and you know they
win and even when they do settle it like
the concussion case you look at and say
man it would have been a hell of a lot
worse if if it had gone south for them
in court and maybe Colin Kaepernick's
case would have been the same way
regardless at some level and even though
every settlement says there is no
admission of liability inherent to this
agreement the reality is you're not
signing the check because you have no
liability at all there is some
responsibility there or you wouldn't be
doing it especially if it's a
significant check like it was so at this
point given everything that's happened
does he merit something more than just
being treated like any other 32 year old
free agent quarterback should there be
an effort by the league to find a team
like they did with Michael Sam when they
wanted Michael Sam in the league they
found a team you're right they called
they cried they got a deal with Jeff
Fischer to draft him in round seven and
then when the rams cut him they got the
Cowboys to put him on the practice squad
I remember Peter King reporting that
from Denver I think it was our Seattle
or somewhere on that opening night of
the season 2014 it would have been
Seattle so I look I don't know I think
that maybe we need when I heard that
word repair yesterday it got me thinking
this is something more than the normal
course of business well it doesn't need
they need to repair the damage they did
to Colin Kaepernick and I don't know
they're willing to do it but that's
maybe what they need to do well to sign
them to a team would certainly go a long
way I do think it would kind of bring
everybody together in the lead and maybe
it would start a different type of
awareness to start the season maybe
there would be a different type of
message maybe kneeling for the anthem
wouldn't happen and that not become an
issue if Colin Kaepernick does get
signed by a team and you're right this
new rule within the CBA to keep veteran
players you know on the practice squad
as long as you want
it's very real that gives this car it
gives these NFL teams less wiggle room
to justify them you know not bringing in
Colin Kaepernick
you know listen I'll say this if I was a
head coach I bring a minute there's no
doubt about it I'd bring them in I'd
work them out I let's let's see what
he's got okay I don't think you could be
hurt by that you're gonna have to deal
with it
we'll deal with some some scrutiny and
whatever else and some hoopla who cares
but I think realistically just because
you and I both know coaches I do think
the three-year absence right or wrong
and we know it was wrong okay is going
to stop some coaches from doing it we
have an influx of good quarterbacks in
football right now and yeah I think a
lot of coaches are conservative and
don't want to deal with the hoopla to go
on top of that so Mike here's the other
thing here's that point but here's hope
let me hang on let me respond that the
whole point is tough crap you got to
deal with the hoopla here during the
damage that was done to him and tough
crap if he's been out of it for three
years it's your fault that he's been out
for three years I guess you have a pair
of the damage you have to find a way to
give him equal treatment you have to
find a way to give him equal footing you
have to wait to us find a way to
assimilate him back into the league and
you know what if they apply if they
apply a different standard for a short
period of time to Colin Kaepernick do
you really think there's gonna be a
locker room schism over well you know
Colin Kaepernick's looking pretty rough
for your age he's maybe fourth on the
depth chart they're probably gonna cut
him or do you think the players would
say you know what he's working his way
back after a three-year absence that the
teams and the league caused we're fine
with Colin Kaepernick making the team
over the third stringer over the second
stringer because we know what he's gonna
be because he's we've seen what he can
be yes I wouldn't listen
no that's real I the players are gonna
support it a hundred percent
you know I just think they will be I
just listen again this is not me so
don't attack me Mike I'm just telling
you I think they'll be trepidation just
my years of knowing these head coaches
yeah I know it's part of what I know
undergoing hard
we're undergoing I get the world has
changed that's the point
these these coaches I'm around
go ahead go ahead well fancy pony
because it's hard to force any guy onto
a football team for a coach where his
jobs depended on it
no matter how good the cause is it is
just hard that's the reality of it I'm
not trying to say it's don't do it my
other thought of this is if there's a
team or no teams that want to sign him
NFL why don't we hire Colin Kaepernick
to be the face of the movement it's a
long-term contract Colin Kaepernick NFL
social injustice police
you know police minority communities all
that he could be the guy that way too
I'm just throwing that out there I want
to see him play football don't get me
wrong I'm not trying to say anything
different than that but I just know
these coaches and I'm with you it's
stupid I give them a shot and I think
the NFL needs to call teams and try to
force their hand a little bit but I do
think that you know you heard reports I
saw a report from Adam Schefter last
night right or one of the insiders that
was saying that they thought GM's would
be you know that wouldn't happen that
nobody would sign Colin Kaepernick right
or wrong and I know that chair of the
water
yeah go ahead carry the water for the
league carry the water for the teams I
love it when the the insiders who need
to have these great relationships with
the teams will carry the water to make
it less uncomfortable see that's the
problem the teams are getting
uncomfortable so they are turning to
people in the media to help make them
comfortable again and any reporter that
pushes this crap I'm gonna call out I
want to find out who said that and I'm
gonna call him out
Barry Willner the AAP last night with a
column suggesting actually suggesting
and I assume with a straight face the
Colin Kaepernick is better off not
returning to the NFL because he has a
bigger platform now than if he was in
the NFL is nonsense and it makes me
think someone fed it to him as part of
this symbiosis that exists between the
league and the media that covers it
there's some back scratching that
happens from time to time
hey Barry we got an idea for you you
know of have you ever thought about it
this way but that would really be a good
column Colin Kaepernick's better off not
being in the NFL seat right now they're
on the ropes and the question is are
they gonna get off the ropes with the
help of the media or is this movement
gonna punch them through the ropes and
get them to do the right thing and Chris
you said it many times you know how
these coaches are and I
would prefer that to be conjugated as I
know how these coaches have been now the
question is will they change will they
change the way they think about their
team will they change the way they think
about a backup quarterback will they
change their willingness to embrace a
distraction because it's the right thing
to do and if the NFL really wants it to
happen there is a deal to be struck with
an owner somewhere for a Super Bowl for
a draft for something if you really want
to get it done folks
that's the way the sausage is made a lot
of deals get done that's a way to do it
and let me just say this as we wrap up
this topic for now George Floyd's
funeral occurred yesterday in Houston
Cal McNair the owner of the team
attended Bill O'Brien the coach and the
GM attended we heard last week very
heartfelt comments from Bill O'Brien in
the aftermath of this movement that has
been sparked over the past 16 days look
at the Texans quarterback depth chart
and ask yourself
yes AJ McCarron is AJ McCarron the right
guy to back up to Shaun Watson did does
AJ member we heard three years ago well
we can't really sign Collin because his
skill sets different than our starter
right and then we pointed out how many
teams have a backup whose skill set
doesn't match the starter whose skill
set Chris is closer to deshaun Watson
Colin Kaepernick or AJ McCarron yes it's
Colin Kaepernick it's not even close
we're talking about a guy who can sit
the pocket and throw lasers all over the
field and then another guy when the
pocket breaks down he can run and make
things happen with his legs and Watson
and Kaepernick are very similar that way
and you're right it's a BS excuse that
everybody used in the NFL back then and
that makes a lot of sense to down there
in Houston you're certainly right Colin
Kaepernick could certainly help out that
quarterback room there's no doubt about
that and let me just say this then as we
take our break and I don't want to put
unfair pressure on anyone but I think
the obvious outcome here and I think the
right team to do it and when we think of
the word repair we think of the issues
that happened a few years ago in
Texans locker room with Dwayne brown
DeAndre Hopkins the statement that was
made by the late Bob McNair the founder
of the team maybe the repair happens
mutually maybe the repair is that Bill
O'Brien the coach and GM of the team
with the approval not just consent but
with the act of approval of Cal McNair
makes Colin Kaepernick a member of the
team with an opportunity to compete to
be the backup quarterback for 2022
deshaun Watson what's wrong with any of
that right I think it makes perfect
sense it's one of those things that's
hiding in plain sight and I think if
anybody right now should consider doing
it the team that it is in the city where
George florid was born in this moment
during this movement that would go a
long way toward beginning the process of
repairing the repair wouldn't be
complete Chris but it would at least be
a start ya know no doubt about that and
it does make a lot there's a few teams
Mike I've thought about like teams that
can handle the Colin Kaepernick
situation and a guy like the Shaun
Watson ability O'Brien certainly can do
it I thought about Kansas City with
Patrick mahomes being the leader of the
way that would be a great way to do it
too
and then of course the Baltimore Ravens
had John Harbaugh brother Jim coach
Colin Kaepernick you know I think
there's a type of team and have a
culture there that could support it and
be all around it and of course he fits
the seals skill set of the starting
quarterback it would fit in the offense
so you know those are a few that ring
true but I think you bring up a lot of
good points there Mike bottom line is
this isn't going away in response to the
column last night from The Associated
Press suggesting to Colin Kaepernick is
better off not playing I actually put
the reporter hat on made some phone
calls bottom line is this he's in shape
he's ready and he's more motivated than
ever to play so and I know at some point
he's gonna have to accept a veteran
minimum contract at some point he's
gonna have to say I know something other
than I want fifteen million dollars but
to get back in if he has the right
expectations the time is right to do it
we'll see if somebody does the right
thing
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports